happy Halloween region no bad jokes on
Christmas grateful for stupid comedy uh
Happy Thanksgiving Oh all guys
apparently The Lion King teaser trailers
just dropped hoorah
I'm excited to check this out man and
I'm one of those people who's been a
little skeptical about him like yeah I
know Jon Favreau's done a good jungle
book movie do we really need a Lion King
adaptation absolutely we do there's a
lot they didn't achieve with that
animators this would great videos are
made of disagreements arguments YouTube
let's get to it before we do I wanted to
say thank you this is what I'm grateful
for everyone has been following us on
our patreon page over there we do TV
show reaction watch the long-form inia
shows that includes attack on Titan my
hero academia Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood Gotham supernatural
Riverdale condos music video coverage
and we also do weekly Q&A that's a lot
of mumbo-jumbo let's get to this we got
family get-togethers to get to so let's
hurry this long shall we yeah that's the
line
[Music]
[Music]
Wow I'm onboard
I'm here
[Applause]
[Music]
we get on it huh I don't know hey here
so good they got James Richard it's a
real line they really taught that line
how to act
oh yeah he's a great actor - I've heard
he's already about to star in another
franchise oh that's amazing yeah yeah
he's gonna be in The Wizard of Oz remake
it's gonna be great playing this
character out here really big stretch
all right well I've said it time and
time again I'm well aware that these
live-action remakes of Disney Animated
Classics are just exactly that they're
theirs to another 100% not for chakras
chakras makes them for live-action it's
easy to be a cynic about it I don't know
why I just don't tend to fall on the
cynical side usually when I see these
trailers I'm like oh you know again in
thought and in conception of like oh
that's all they do every time I see it
you like Aladdin or whatever
I'm really looking forward to this is
gonna be awesome oh yeah either way you
slice it it's impressive to hold
especially you look at this trailer and
you're like wow this really is just
ripped directly from those drawings yeah
and to see for something like this I
mean you know you have Aladdin coming up
as well which is maybe a little less in
this direction I feel it's something
like The Lion King and also with the
Jungle Book
there is a sort of extra impressive
element because they're all animals
yeah and that's harder to do in
live-action than just staging a lot of
people and having maybe one CG creature
like the beast or something yeah exactly
because when you're looking at these the
images especially of like the any of
these animals here other than baby Simba
yeah baby said what's the only thing
that really looks super CGI to me yeah
but like grownup Simba looks pretty
realistic to me I mean the wildebeest
stampede that they hint at for a hot
second and that shot looks barrowing and
yeah it looks really intense and the
animated movie rafiki's my favorite
character because he doesn't martial
arts yeah maybe they're never smiling
and stuff yeah in real life these kinds
of apes are a lot more low-key and a lot
more intense you know a lot less friend
leaving in the cartoons you know don't
bite into everything you see in the
cartoons gee I guess why this is pretty
miraculous to me going off at the point
that you're making when I heard that
they're doing this I'm like there's no
humans in here and I feel like usually
what makes these live adaptations cool
as you're gonna see real life people
bring this you know to life when I heard
that they're doing this like it's just
gonna be a bunch of animated animals
again in real life backdrops there is
something really magical to it when
you're looking at it going oh they look
like real animals that's cool something
we've tried to do in movies for a book
pull it off yeah and we are finally
getting I think to the point where we
can sell that for an entire movie and
it's not a cheesy gag you know cuz there
have been a lot of movies that have
attempted it
better worse results but I feel like
yeah this is kind of a feat yeah of
itself that's something to behold for
sure you get teases of like with the
wildebeest I'm assuming that's the scene
that occurs it's a Steve I made me cry
so hard as a child
yeah this looks really epic it's
shot-for-shot to me Jon Favreau's Jungle
Book I prefer that over the animated
movie so I imagine he's not only going
to do direct rip I imagine he's gonna
bring something that makes it unique I
find it very hard to believe you could
ever top the animated movie because
that's just like perfect no I would put
James Earl Jones is Mufasa in the
animated movie right yeah now he's
playing scar that's right yeah they're
going did he record the same lines over
again or did they just take his part you
could do that and and the movie might
not have anything how direct of a rip it
is yeah I'm not altogether shocked that
we didn't get any hints of the music but
I kind of wish that we got a note or
something because that's one of the big
things I'm wondering about here because
like the jungle book movie had like a
couple songs you know carried over and I
know that they're gonna carry like four
I think over from this and I'm just
really curious to hear how they're gonna
rework them cuz I guess Elton John came
in to rework his stuff yeah with Beyonce
and then you have Hans Zimmer doing the
rest of the score score so yes makes me
wonder what this makes really upbeat
Disney music there's gonna be probably
that fun adventure Hans Zimmer vibe with
some of that you know with some African
traditional music worked in I would hope
anyway yeah that's true I mean I
remember Beauty and the Beast they added
an original song with the beast and that
outdid everyone everyone the best part
in Italy at best this makes me happy I'm
excited to check this movie out I
I'm looking forward to it you know I'm
hoping this film because it's
live-action there's dark elements in the
liking some real dramatic hard-hitting
moments that occur that I won't go over
specifically because in case you happen
to have not seen the anime there's some
pretty dark elements in here I don't
know how full-on dark they can go with
it however I think it would be cool to
kind of push that envelope just a little
bit extra in a live-action version yeah
you know and that have super tonal
inconsistencies with having some really
funny humor with Timon and Pumbaa they
go really dark and serious then go back
to the hyenas you know what I'm really
hoping for is that since this is all
under the Disney umbrella you know that
they sort of uncover at some point like
a stronghold of vibranium and then the
cumin is kind of you know come in the
Black Panther has to team up with Simba
and then there's a sequel where it's
black panther and Simba together like
that's what I'm hoping happens from this
cuz Africa and Wakanda and America and
you know black people and it's it's
great John don't be racist I'm such a
racist
I hate all people like me listen I don't
want to play favoritism here but I'm
gonna give a patron today shoutout to a
woman named Rosa Parra Rosa I know that
you've had quite an interesting year
this past year I know that you are a
strong mother to John and I and you can
thank you are to your children your
actual blood children but let's face it
you're a much better mom to us than you
are to them it's kind of weird that your
mom has a crush on one of her sons and
it kind of weirdly fulfills John's other
issues so yes I guess it works well for
you guys I wanted to say thank you so
much for being a part of our patreon
page for so long
I know you wanted us to show you out at
a game of Thrones related video
nothing's dropped I don't think
anything's gonna drop this month for a
while but I figured this is the closest
to Game of Thrones it's gonna get oh
yeah I love you dearly and I hope you
have a happy Thanksgiving
and thank you to all watching stay safe
today if you drink and drive
make sure there's no cops on the road
and
drive to the reject nation click that
notification Bell be kind to your
parents be kind to your children carry a
knife and catch you on patreon
take care